have you ever noticed that the police
cars in your country are almost always
made by national automakers in america
they use ford chevrolet and dodge in
germany they use bmw audi and volkswagen
in japan they use nissan toyota and so
on and so forth this makes sense
countries want to support national
automakers because this creates jobs
financially backs automakers to rough
times and displaced national pride
throughout the police force yet despite
tesla being american and the most valued
car company in the world the american
police doesn't really bother with teslas
now of course there are examples of
certain counties around the us using a
few teslas here and there but for the
most part the american police has stuck
to their routes with over 50 percent of
police vehicles still being manufactured
by ford so here's why the american
police shy away from using teslas
starting off with the surface level
reasons we have customization police
cars aren't a new invention by any means
the first police car dates back to 1899
when a police department in ohio started
testing an electric-powered wagon
throughout the early 1900s many police
departments around the us started
playing around with their own police
vehicles but all of these were
individual ventures for example a police
commissioner in detroit named frank
crawl had the idea of creating police
cars he asked the city if they would
invest in police vehicles but they
declined the opportunity so frank ended
up investing 5 000 of his own money to
buy a packard and modded for police use
after seeing the result detroit actually
purchased six more vehicles from frank
and this led to many other sectors in
detroit adopting cars as well
these cars weren't for chasing criminals
though originally the purpose of these
police cars was to improve the
effectiveness of each police officer
with their car each police officer could
cover a lot more area which saved a lot
of money long term but getting your
hands on police vehicles wasn't an easy
process by any means for the most part
police departments and chiefs had to
take on the responsibility of modding
cars themselves and this was often an
extremely long and tedious process it
took a police officer named kenneth cox
six years to figure out how to install a
radio into the back seat of a ford model
t
now given that he's a police officer and
not a car mechanic i don't blame him but
i think it's easy to see why police
departments found this customization
process quite annoying this all changed
in 1950 when ford introduced something
called the police package ford had been
taking notes on the most common mods
police departments had made to their
vehicles and ford combined all of these
mods into the police package five years
later in 1955 chevrolet came out with
their own police package and dodge
followed behind in 1956
and with that police departments were
finally able to get out of the modding
business after 50 years
most police departments had no urge to
return to the business but today if they
want to use a tesla that's exactly what
they have to do
the fremont police department is one of
the few counties that use a few teslas
in their fleet and they actually made a
list of all the mods they had to make to
the tesla this includes overhead light
bars and sirens police vehicle radios
prisoner partitions and so on and so
forth i'm sure tesla will eventually
come out with the police package but
that's simply not a top priority right
now
and that brings us to the second issue
which is scale despite being the most
valid car company in the world tesla is
still quite a small automaker when it
comes to vehicle output tesla is
increasing their production
exponentially year after year but
they're still yet to crack even one
million cars per year which means that
they still have a lot of room to grow
within the consumer market itself so it
makes little sense to tend to niche
markets like the police or fire
department when you still have so much
primary growth left i mean the legacy
american automakers ignored the police
department for 50 years it wasn't until
their first car boom settled down that
they turned their focus onto the police
department
so we may not see a tesla police package
until the first ev adoption boom is
behind us moving on likely the most
obvious factor holding back tesla
adoption is price though tesla likes to
market prices like 35 000 for the model
3 this is simply not true
to get that price they factor in a
lifetime of gas savings and any tax
incentives they can find
that price also does not include the
1200 delivery fee associated with buying
a tesla not to mention you have to pay
extra to have any color other than white
assuming that most police departments
want a black car that tacks on another
one thousand dollars onto the purchase
price
and what about range for highway patrol
cars the range is a pretty important
consideration the starting price of the
long range model three is fifty thousand
dollars add in everything we just talked
about and you're looking at about fifty
five thousand dollars and don't forget
we haven't even factored in the police
specific mods that generally cost about
ten thousand dollars so if you want a
decent model 3 patrol car you're looking
at a total out-of-pocket cost of 65
grand to put that in perspective the
2021 ford explorer police interceptor
utility starts at just 42 grand
even if you pump it up with some options
you're only looking at a total cost of
50 grand
not only is the ford explorer 15 000
cheaper but it's an suv as opposed to a
sedan
over the past decade the american police
have really been embracing suvs due to
their superior interior space higher
seating position and a greater carrying
capacity tesla doesn't make a proper suv
and so the only benefit you get from the
tesla is that it's electric if you want
self-driving the price disparity would
grow to 25 000
i know a lot of you guys will mention
that the tesla will be cheaper to run
and maintain and that they'll cost about
the same over the long term
there's no arguing against the low
maintenance bill of the tesla but the
gas savings may not actually be that
significant for police departments
here's the thing police cars don't pay
the same amount for gas as we do in most
cases the police department has its own
gas pumps and they're able to source
discounted subsidized gas through the
government smaller departments without
gas pumps often have deals with local
gas stations to get cheaper gas
something else to consider is that
police departments are exempt from
certain taxes which also reduces the gas
bill but even if we ignored all of this
and gave tesla the benefit of the doubt
and said that the tesla would be the
same price over the long term the
decision likely wouldn't change with the
tight police budgets and sometimes even
budget deficits the upfront cost of
purchasing the vehicles is simply a
bigger concern than the long-term cost
those are the logical reasons that the
police have thus far stayed away from
tesla but there's a couple of political
and bureaucratic factors as well
starting with social backlash in america
there is a demographic of people who
don't particularly like the police
in fact many of them think that police
funding should be cut and that the
department should be abolished
altogether
now of course that's the extreme end of
the spectrum but even people who are
relatively in the middle often don't
want to splurge on the police department
and while you may be able to objectively
support investing into eb police
vehicles for long-term cost benefits as
well as environmental benefits the same
cannot be said about the general public
tesla has an image of being the cool car
company they have self-driving cars they
have modern interiors they support
leading-edge technology and the company
is led by elon musk this positive public
image has done the company quite a bit
of good as consumers view tesla as a
luxury car maker and desire their cars
though the general public desires teslas
they don't see it as a necessity they
see it as a nice to have luxury product
and many of them don't like seeing tax
dollars being spent on nice to have
luxuries the counties that have bought
teslas for police use have experienced
the backlash first hand take the
hastings on hudson police department in
new york for example in december they
took delivery of a model white police
car and posted about it on twitter they
explained that the purchase would help
the department move towards
environmental sustainability and that
they would actually save money on gas
long term but twitter users weren't
quite convinced this user replied this
is what we mean when we say defund the
police all that extra money can be used
to better the communities they serve
this other user replied this wtf we mean
when we say defund the police people
starving and struggling to pay the rent
and somehow you fit tesla's in the
budget there were dozens of replies just
like these and whether this criticism is
deserved or not is besides the point the
truth is the criticism has more to do
with the brand of their car than the
price of the car the hudson police
department could have bought a more
expensive ford or chevrolet and no one
would have cared because those brands
don't carry the same social status as
tesla's so the easy way to avoid this
drama is simply avoiding teslas and that
brings me into the final and possibly
the most influential factor which is the
bureaucratic nature of government the
government is extremely slow when it
comes to change regardless of how big or
small the change is and how big or small
the benefits are the government tends to
embrace a policy of if it ain't broke
don't fix it for example in the 1980s
the police settled in on a favorite
vehicle the ford crown victoria i bet
all of you guys are familiar with this
vehicle as it was extremely popular for
such a long period of time
law enforcement in the us and canada
used the crown victoria as their
dominant police vehicle for 19 years
that's literally as long as the entire
company of tesla has been around i'm
sure that many police departments have
existing partnerships connections and
deals with legacy automakers which just
further dissuades them from switching to
tesla something else to consider is that
ford has been coming out with some
outstanding evs the maki has been a
massive success and it looks like the
ford f-150 lightning is actually going
to hit the market before the cyber truck
also the maquis just became the first
all-electric vehicle to pass the
michigan state police pursuit vehicle
test last week and ford is already
looking to build purpose-built electric
police vehicles so ford is by no means
ready to give up the police market
combine this with all the factories we
already outlined and i don't think we'll
be seeing the police using tesla and
mass anytime soon do you disagree
comment that down below
also drop a like if you're glad that
tesla is at the very least pushing
forward ev adoption within the police
force and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm ari and i'll see you
guys on the next one